it is April 2nd day 2 of 30 of the new
30 days to stop the spread I will
officially update you daily on the
numbers for the time being official
coronavirus case toll as of right now
954 thousand yesterday we had almost 77
thousand new cases official death toll
as of this moment 48,000 558 yesterday
almost 5,000 coronavirus deaths in one
day in the u.s. we officially have more
than two hundred and fifteen thousand
cases now over 5100 deaths more than 100
deaths yesterday alone for the first
time and those numbers will likely
worsen the latest modelling expects
ninety three thousand five hundred
deaths in the United States during this
first wave of infection peaking on April
15 that model is adjusted daily based on
the previous day's case and death data
we have the latest job loss numbers and
they are jarring visually when you see
these numbers on a graph it almost looks
like someone made a mistake with the
graph but it is no mistake the number of
Americans filing for unemployment last
week was a record-breaking 6.6 million
people so last week I gave you the prior
week's numbers and those were 3.3
million new jobless claims the expected
number was 1.6 million the actual was
3.3 about double last week the
expectation was 3.7 million the real
number almost double 6.6 for 8 million
new jobless claims when you look at the
numbers on a graph it almost seems like
a joke but it is all too real so to
contextualise this 3.3 followed by 6.6
new jobless claims over the last two
weeks before two weeks ago the record
for new jobless claims in one week was
695 thousand that was back in 1982 now
the population was smaller in 1982
roughly adjusting these numbers for
today's population 695 thousand in 1982
would be about a million today
so again two weeks ago 3.3 million new
claims last week 6.6 million new claims
to say that this is a historic situation
doesn't even really do it justice it
will take a very very long time to
recover now Donald Trump continues to
insist it will be quick easy fast and we
will get to a better point than we were
before the pandemic hit there is no
doubt that when things start to open
back up there will be elements that will
recover relatively quickly but much of
this will not especially considering
that we're likely medical experts who
are the people we should be listening to
medical experts believe we're gonna see
a second wave in the fall of this year
and then possibly a third wave of
infection in early 2021 we may still not
have a vaccine at that point in time
now the follow-on problems with the
unemployment claims are huge the first
problem is that the unemployment
insurance systems which are administered
at the state level are failing in many
cases because they're overwhelmed quite
simply Universal unemployment insurance
benefits are administered at the state
level so you've got like the Department
of Employment and training in
Massachusetts which runs unemployment
insurance here in Massachusetts each
state has their own system some states
require you to file by phone some are
web-based some are a combination
whatever widespread reports of whatever
system each state has in place being
simply unable to keep up phone lines so
overloaded that you can't even get on
hold in other words the hold system is
full and you just have to try to call
back at some other point so we have more
people than ever trying to file for
unemployment benefits meanwhile the
systems can't even keep up so of course
if that means some people aren't getting
their money when they deserve it or when
they could otherwise get it it's early
April right now rent is due
mortgages are due and thus that is going
to have follow-on effects like we
discussed yesterday on the bonus show
because people who should be getting
unemployment benefits can't get them
they can't pay their rent they can't pay
their mortgages and on and on
on so now the next big number to come
out will be tomorrow Friday April 3rd we
are going to get we are expecting the
full March unemployment numbers bear in
mind they probably aren't going to
capture the full scope of the problem
because remember some states have only
issued stay-at-home orders in the last
24 hours
some states still have not done that I
think there's eight or ten states that
have not officially done anything yet
although maybe it's city and town levels
things are being done so the full scope
of the problem is not even going to be
known with the April numbers maybe in
the May numbers which will tell us early
May we will get the April numbers is
what I mean
we might get a sense of something closer
to the full scope of this now at the
same time hopefully by the end of May we
will start to be in some kind of
recovery where some people can start
getting back to work but that may not
happen I don't want to put the cart
before the horse because that may not
happen very difficult time for tens of
millions of people in the United States
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works when you pay for
something online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number privacy lets you generate
virtual card numbers the payments are
withdrawn from your checking account but
your real card number stays completely
private and you do it all with one click
you can autofill the card number in your
web browser on the phone you can create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that have
and unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free they
do have a paid version with different
tiers where you can create more virtual
credit card numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no-brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up when you go
to privacy comm slash Pakman